[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99 designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them for book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one York Times
best seller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers in illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99designs
com forward slash Tim 9 and Designs has
freelance experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for extra design help resources
etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs comm forward slash
Tim and click the link on the landing
page you can also find their samples of
projects from you guys listeners who
have used 99 designs for logos apps even
product packaging so check it out 99
designs com forward slash Tim
hello my darling Nitin Mogwai this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to interview world-class
performers from every discipline
imaginable to tease out the habits the
patterns the belief systems favorite
books whatever it might be that you can
apply to your own life and this episode
is going to be a slightly different
format you will get what I just
mentioned and it will be with one of the
biggest surprise hit guests that I've
ever had on the podcast and you wanted
me to have him back on to pick up where
we left off and to ask the rapid-fire
questions that are your favorites which
we didn't get to and that is the purpose
of this recording and he does deliver
his name is Adam so without further ado
let's get into it our guest today is
Adam Robinson you can find him on
Twitter at I am Adam Robinson or at
Robinson global strategies.com
Adam has made a lifelong study of
outflanking and outsmarting the
competition he is rated Chessmaster and
has been awarded a life master title by
the United States Chess Federation as a
teenager he was personally mentored by
Bobby Fischer in the 18 months leading
up to his winning the World Championship
and Adam and I talked a lot about this
in our first conversation on the Tim
Ferriss show which you guys can check
out but back to the bio then in Adam's
first career he developed a
revolutionary approach to taking
standardized tests as one of the two
original cofounders of the Princeton
Review his paradigm breaking or category
killing as they say in publishing test
prep book cracking the system the SAT is
the only test prep book to have ever
become a New York Times bestseller after
selling his interest in the Princeton
Review Adam turned his attention in the
early 90s to the then emerging field of
artificial intelligence developing a
program that could analyze text and
provide human-like commentary he was
later invited to join a well known quant
fund to develop statistical trading
models and since he has established
himself as an independent global macro
advisor to the chief investment
officer's of a select group of the
world's most successful hedge funds and
ultra high
birth family offices if you could have a
gigantic billboard anywhere with
anything on it what would it say and why
well first Tim thanks for having me back
it's always a great joy and a privilege
and a pleasure
I leave aside the danger of having a
text-heavy billboard that would distract
passing drivers instead I'll focus on
four core quotes I lived my life by to
buy others and to buy me first the two
quotes by others
the first is Rudyard Kipling if you did
not get what you want it's a sign either
that you did not seriously want it or
you tried to bargain over the price and
the second quote is Amelia Earhart's the
most difficult thing is the decision to
act the rest is merely tenacity Kipling
Anne Earhart almost captured the secret
to achievement but we need to qualify
them because they can lead to obstinate
persistence either the goals or methods
that aren't working and because they
ignore or dismiss the emotional
component of achieving goals so I'll add
two quotes of my own and the first and I
think this is my favorite personal quote
if you're not getting the results you
want change what you're doing you'd
think that would be obvious you'd think
people of course would change they would
pivot but they don't they do more the
same they double down on what they've
already done they try harder okay so how
do you change what you're doing a good
starting point is to take a step in the
opposite direction so if you've been
spending a lot of money spend less if
you've been making a lot of phone calls
make fewer phone calls or none at all so
these new steps might not work either
in which case change and change again
keep pivoting until you find something
that works and then do more of that
my second quote is if you experience any
negative emotion doubt fear frustration
anger it's almost always a sign to
redirect your attention either to the
task at hand or to others Michael Jordan
once said that he's never thought about
missing a shot and the reason he's never
thought about missing a shot is that
attention is totally focused on making
the shot so it would be wrong to say
that Michael Jordan was self confident
about making the shot because the
attention there would be focused not on
making the shot but on himself so
self-confidence in this sense is almost
as bad as self-doubt your attention is
focused on the wrong thing it's focused
on yourself as opposed to the shot
you're trying to make or the task at
hand whatever it might be or the other
the other person so I have dozen
actually hundreds of other quotes that
resonate with how I live my life but for
a billboard I would confine myself to
those four what are bad recommendations
that you hear in your profession or area
of expertise
my field is that of global finance and
virtually all investors have been told
when they were younger were implicitly
believe or have been tacitly encouraged
to do so by the cookie cutter
curriculums of business schools they all
attend that the more they understand the
world the better their investment
results it makes sense doesn't it the
more information we acquire and evaluate
the air quotes better informed we become
and the better our decisions
accumulating information becoming better
informed is certainly an advantage in
numerous if not most fields but not in
the counterintuitive world of investing
we're accumulating information can
actually hurt your investment results so
in 1974 Paul slovic a world-class
psychologist and a peer of Nobel
laureate Daniel Kahneman decided to
evaluate the effect of information on
decision making this study should be
taught at every business school in the
country Slavik gathered eight
professional horse handicappers and
announced to them I want to see how well
you predict the winners of horse races
now these handicappers were all seasoned
professionals who made their living
solely on their gambling skills slovak
told them the test would consist of
predicting 40 horse races in four
consecutive rounds in the first round
each gambler would be given the five
pieces of information he wanted on each
horse which would vary from handicapper
to handicapper 1 handicapper for example
might want the years of experience that
jockey has had as
one of his top five variables while
another might not care at all about that
but want the fastest speed for any given
horse it achieved in the past year or
the weight of the jockey or whatever
finally in addition to asking the
handicappers to predict the winner of
each race he asked each one to also
state how confident he was in his
prediction now as it turns out there
were an average of ten horses in each
race so we would expect by blind chance
random guessing that each handicapper
would be right 10% of the time that
their confidence with a blind guess to
be 10% so in round one let's see how
they did with just five pieces of
information the handicappers were 17%
accurate which is pretty good actually
70% better than the 10% chance they
started with given zero pieces of
information and interestingly their
confidence was 19% almost exactly as
confident as they should have been
they were 17% accurate and 19% confident
in their predictions excellent
calibration in round two they were then
given ten pieces of information in round
three twenty and in the fourth and final
round each handicapper was given 40
pieces of information that's a whole lot
more statistics than the five pieces of
information
they each started with surprisingly
their accuracy had flatlined at 17% they
were no more accurate with the
additional 35 pieces of information they
had unfortunately their confidence in
their predictions had nearly doubled to
31% so the additional information made
them no more accurate but a whole lot
more confident which would have led them
to increase the size of their bets and
lose money as a result beyond a certain
amount of information a certain minimal
amount additional information only feeds
confirmation bias leaving aside the
considerable cost and delay occasioned
in acquiring that information the
additional information we gain that
conflicts with our original assessment
or conclusion we conveniently ignore or
dismiss while the information that
confirms our original decision makes us
increasingly certain
that our conclusion was correct so to
return to investing the second problem
with trying to understand the world is
that it is simply far too complex to
grasp and the more dog at our attempts
to understand the world the more
earnestly we want to explain that's air
quotes explain events and trans in it
the more we become attached to our
resulting beliefs which are almost
always more or less mistaken blinding us
to the financial trends that are
actually unfolding right in front of our
eyes worse we think we understand the
world giving us a false sense of
confidence when in fact we are almost
always more or less mistaken you hear
all the time from even the most seasoned
investors and financial expert that this
trend or that doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense the dollar keeps
going lower or it makes no sense that
stocks keep going higher but what's
really going on when investors say that
something makes no sense is that they
have a dozen or whatever reasons why the
trend should be moving in the opposite
direction yet it keeps moving in the
current direction so they believe the
trend air quotes makes no sense but what
makes no sense is their model of the
world
that's what doesn't make sense the world
always makes sense we just don't
understand it
in fact because financial trends involve
human behavior and human beliefs on a
global scale the most powerful trends
won't make sense until it becomes too
late to profit from them by the time
investors formulate an understanding
again a false understanding that gives
them the feeling of confidence to invest
the investment opportunity has likely
already passed so when I hear
sophisticated investors or financial
commentators say for example that it
makes no sense how energy stocks keep
going lower I know that energy stocks
have a lot lower to go because all those
investors are on the wrong side of the
trade in denial
probably doubling down on their original
decision to buy energy stocks eventually
they'll be forced to throw in the towel
and have to sell those energy stocks
driving prices still lower what is one
of the best or most worthwhile
investments you've ever made I've made
many investments in my life money of
time of energy of passion
and emotion and one of the best payoffs
for the amount invested was learning to
meditate
I've always been driven excited by the
world so my mind is continually racing
at a thousand miles per hour pursuing
this question or that creating this
system or that non-stop 24 hours a day
365 days a year 300 266 on leap years
now all that non-stop mental and psychic
stimulation gets exhausting of course
and if you want to perform optimally at
anything you need to find a way to
recover from the stresses of that
activity so I knew that though I should
find a way to turn off my mind and air
quotes just relax just enjoy just be for
years I had failed to find a way I tried
everything
Yoga exercise I even tried hypnosis I
researched once the best hypnotist in
New York City as a way to somehow turn
off my hyperactive mind but after four
attempted and hugely expensive sessions
with this guy the hypnotist gave up
saying your mind is too active to submit
to the hypnosis well thanks a lot doc I
told I'm not concealing my annoyance
that's exactly why I had come to him
then about two years ago my bestie Josh
Waitzkin recognizing that I couldn't
unwind or disengage from my relentless
analyzing the world especially the
financial world recommended that I take
up meditation sorry I said it doesn't
work for me I can't sit still long
enough for any benefits of meditating to
kick in so he asked have you ever tried
heart rate variability training HRV
training and I said no what's that he
said that you just focused on your
breathing using biofeedback to measure
the smoothness and the amplitude hence
the word variability of your heart rate
the heart not surprisingly registers all
our real-time emotions and stresses so
the normal heart beat is highly erratic
staying within a tight band around an
average
the goal with the biofeedback training
is to gain control over your own heart
rate by focusing on your breathing
making your jagat heart rate smooth out
like a sine curve and to widen its
amplitude that sounded interesting but
it wasn't until I reframed meditation
that I submitted to trying it
the problem with meditation I thought
was that it wasn't practical and worse
the time I spent meditating was time I
could have spent analyzing the world but
I eventually reframed meditation as a
way to relinquish control of my
conscious mind so that my more powerful
unconscious mind could take over and my
analysis of the world would improve
motivated by that reframing I
enthusiastically and opted biofeedback
HRV training and in a few weeks learned
to quiet my mind after just a single
deep diaphragm belly breath gaining the
ability to achieve a zen-like calm on
demand now whenever I need to detach
from the world or from the stresses of
daily life and to allow my mind a rest I
simply get centered and inhale from my
diaphragm and I do so numerous times a
day a minute here a minute there and at
least once a day I waste that's air
quotes I waste a larger 15 to 20 minute
block of time meditating in this way but
it's not wasted time of course since the
increased creativity and productivity
from these many restorative sessions is
far more valuable than the time I spend
being unproductive again air quotes
while meditating meditation is one of
the most practical powerful productivity
enhancing tools ever created and
learning to meditate is one of the best
investments I've ever made what purchase
of 100 dollars or less has most
positively impacted your life in the
last six months or in recent memory well
this purchase is not less than a hundred
dollars but at 159 it is too close to
pass up the heart math inner balance
biofeedback monitor it detects your
hearts my nudist rhythms and sent a
graph to your smartphone facilitating
HRV training and while you're at it get
the
book heart math solution in the last
five years
what new beliefs behavior or habit has
most improved your life the
understanding which has become a habit
that is most improved my life in the
last five years dramatically so is
recognizing the importance of others in
not only changing the world but in
enjoying it by nature I'm an introvert
so much so that some friends revealed
after high school that there were
students classmates of mine who had
never seen me speak not once in all of
high school by the time I graduated from
Oxford after doing my undergraduate work
at the Wharton School at the University
of Pennsylvania I'd begun to emerge from
my interior world to a great extent but
I was still ninety five to five on the
introvert extrovert scale I very much
enjoyed the company of other people but
only for brief periods 15 30 minutes
beyond which I'd reach overload and I
need to seclude myself to recharge after
college in my career my success in the
world was the product of my insights and
imagination and thinking so I inhabited
the world of ideas far more than I did
the world of people the more and better
ideas I came up with the more success I
achieved so it came as a surprise
relatively late in life
in fact only in the past year that if
you want to change the world you have to
enroll others in your plans and vision
not only that but I discovered the
immense pleasures and satisfactions that
can be derived from focusing on others
and putting them first and the
surprising discovery that the more I
gave to others which I'd always done the
more the universe gave me back in return
whereas in the past when I went outside
and encountered others I would
invariably be lost in thought now I am
solely focused not inwardly on my ideas
but outwardly on connecting with others
I mentioned this discovery publicly for
the first time in a live group podcast I
did with you Tim back in December 2016
and was inspired shortly thereafter to
write a book an invitation to the great
game a parable of love magic
everyday miracles in which I articulate
my three guiding rules of life first
whenever possible connect with others
second with enthusiasm strive always to
create fun of the light for others and
third lean into each moment and every
encounter expecting magic or miracles
this discovery so profoundly altered my
life path revealing for the first time I
true mission on this planet that I now
divide my life into two periods pre
discovery of others and post discovery
now I so eagerly look forward to leaving
my home each day wondering what magic
I'll create encountering others that I
can scarcely contain myself my days now
have a natural rhythm between
introversion and extraversion that is
akin to breathing when I'm alone I
inhale my ideas and then I exhale with
others the number of remarkable people
and Serendipity's and successes that
have come into my life since I've
adopted this awareness of others which
quickly developed into a reflexive habit
of directing my attention solely on them
when I am NOT alone has been nothing
short of astonishing so Tim I have to
thank you for inspiring that book with
that question at the 92nd Street Y what
have you learned this past year and the
book an invitation of the great game
will be coming out soon in January what
advice would you give to a smart driven
college student about to enter the real
world
yikes I could write a book in response
to this question so instead I'll just
toss out a hodgepodge of observations
truths Maxim's caveats and exhortations
that I wish I had known or at least
fully appreciated when I just entered
the real world myself
congratulations you recently left or
you'll soon be leaving an ecosystem
you've known your whole life for an
entirely new one to switch analogies
you're leaving a game you've played
since at least first grade with the rule
book you've consciously if not
unconsciously assimilated and more or
less mastered for an entirely new game
with no
formal rulebook handed out you'll have
to write your own rulebook you'd think
the point of education would be to
prepare you for the real world
but the real world is more unlike school
than like it indeed you'll find that
many of the traits and habits and
behaviors that served you well in school
will either not work in the real world
or will work against you so you'll have
to adopt an experimental attitude
towards everything continually testing
what works for you and what doesn't
graduating from college or leaving
behind your formal schooling whatever
form it took to enter the real world is
a major step since it marks the first
time in your life when you'll be making
most of the decisions that affect that
life rather than being told what to do
or being assigned what to do you won't
receive a clear course syllabus every
few months detailing the assignments and
exactly what is expected of you and the
standards by which a single person your
professor will evaluate your work and
award you a single letter grade so
you'll have to find your own incentives
another enormous difference is that for
the first time you won't be needing to
navigate simply a cohort of peers more
or less exactly your age and from very
similar backgrounds if not aspirations
no longer now you'll be interacting with
a broad spectrum of humanity in all its
delightful but sometimes challenging
diversity so you'll need to acquire a
whole new set of people skills and ways
to relate to others and cultivate what's
known as emotional intelligence
so the rhythms of your life from the
daily to the weekly to the monthly to
the yearly will be ones you establish on
your own rather than the structures and
timetables dictated by the academic
calendar year you'll find this lack of
structure more or less disorienting and
the more you develop routines daily and
weekly at least the better another
recommendation instead of asking
yourself air quotes what you want to do
ask rather who do you want to be
whatever you're doing for work whatever
throw yourself into it wholeheartedly
even if you realize it's a transitional
gig while you search for something
better
don't ever
that air quotes you'll be doing this for
the rest of your life you won't but if
that's your attitude you're missing out
on the next point if there were a single
quality underappreciated by recent
graduates that will most ensure your
career success it's not the obvious ones
like intelligence and good habits and
discipline and the capacity for hard
work but rather this enthusiasm in all
matters be enthusiastic and others will
want to be around you including work
with you and you'll flourish unrelenting
enthusiasm I can't recommend that
strongly enough unrelenting as long as
you're following all the other rules
here have patience life moves it once
much slower than you expect and much
faster you can be doing everything right
paying your dues and for months or years
it seems like you're not making any
progress and then all of a sudden boom
your life explodes forward at Lightspeed
Benjamin Disraeli said that the secret
to success was being ready for your
opportunity when it presents itself
until then pay your dues your success in
the world rests largely on your ability
to create compelling positive visions of
the future that others feel irresistible
drawn to be a part of that goes not only
for your professional life but also for
your personal and even romantic life as
early as you can try to connect to your
personal mission who are you here on
this planet to be Mark Twain said the
two most important days in your life are
the day you're born and the day you
discover why I promise you the sooner
you become aware of a mission larger
than yourself that you are devoted to
the exponentially more rapidly your
personal and professional goals will be
achieved find out what you love to do
and do best and cultivate that talent or
talents then be relentless in finding
jobs or situations in which those
strengths and passions are most in
demand know what your hammer is in a
sense and then look for nails to hit the
most important gifts and goals in life
including love success and happiness
are never achieved I want to underscore
that never achieved by pursuing them
directly
those people focused on finding love for
example have their attention and
priorities diverted from being the kind
of loving lovable person that would
actually attract the love they're
looking for and if your focus is on
becoming successful or wealthy or
whatever your attention isn't focused on
the activities and tasks and others that
will actually lead to that success and
wealth love success and Happiness catch
you best by surprise while your
attention is focused on doing in the
world and being your best self in that
world when you feel overwhelmed or
unfocused what do you do when I'm
feeling unfocused the first question I
ask myself is am i rehearsing my best
self and if the answer is no I ask
myself how I can reset each day presents
us with 86400 seconds which means each
day presents us with virtually countless
opportunities to reset recover our
balance and continue rehearsing our best
selves if I realize my focus is off and
certainly when I'm experiencing any
negative emotions I ask myself where
should my attention be right now almost
always the answer is my mission which is
like a beacon that always beckons but
sometimes I take on too many commitments
because I sometimes have trouble saying
no to others eager to work with me I can
become a bit over committed and
overwhelmed so when that happens rather
than attempting to do everything badly I
ask myself what activity or commitment
can I cut out right now that will free
up the most time reminds me in a funny
way this news story I read ages ago
about a small European town I won't say
what country lest I offend it
unnecessarily in which the postal
workers had trouble keeping up with
their deliveries so on Monday they do
their best to deliver the mail but
they'd have some pieces left over which
they'd add to Tuesday's delivery pile
Tuesday they'd fall further behind of
course and Wednesday and Thursday
further still by Friday
they'd have an enormous pile of
undelivered mail which they burn so they
could start fresh on Monday the process
would repeat the next week a small
bonfire every Friday purging their
delivery vans of that week's undelivered
mail now that was a highly dubious way
of resetting each week which I don't
recommend but the idea of having a fresh
restart whenever overwhelmed is
excellent so let's say by noon on any
given day I'm falling behind and it's
clear I'm in danger of becoming
overwhelmed in short order rather than
attempting to keep all of my afternoon
appointments which I'd reach later and
later in that as the day progressed I
scan my calendar and I ask myself which
is the earliest appointment as it were I
can burn by postponing it to another day
I'd rather reschedule one appointment
and make the other three on time than be
late and frazzled for all four
appointments that afternoon
speaking of which each week I leave one
day completely open and schedule a
pretend trip out of the city so that I'm
not tempted to fill it in anyway not
even meeting with friends or having
other fun diversions then if an
emergency arises or I fall behind and
become overwhelmed I know I have a free
day air quotes a free day to use any way
I'd like so when I get overwhelmed
trying to juggle too many balls
simultaneously I ask myself which one or
two balls can I set down for the moment
so that I can get caught up on all the
others in the last five years what have
you become better at saying no to this
is such an important lesson being able
to say no it's especially hard for me
because of my inherent optimism and my
unflagging enthusiasm and because they
always lean into each moment in every
encounter expecting magic or miracles
and because life has rewarded me
increasingly with tantalizing offers so
I not infrequently say yes too often to
my regret because I wind up overloading
my cognitive or physical or energy
bandwidths or simply run out of time so
I've found a powerfully useful editing
principle as it were in deciding whether
to say yes or no to any particular
request or proposal or invitation
or opportunity is answering the
following question while saying yes to
this option advance any important goals
in my life especially my calling or my
mission the cheap point there is to have
a personal mission in the world which
will not only give you a stronger sense
of direction and structure and energy
and motivation personally as well as
professionally but it's also a filter
with which you can decide whether to say
yes to any particular short-term or
long-term options or opportunities that
arise for you on any given day keep in
mind that the time spent on pursuits not
related to your mission is time that
could have been spent on it not that all
your time of course should be devoted to
your mission you'll have other goals in
your life personal and professional and
sometimes you'll just want to goof off
or otherwise enjoy yourself but the
sooner you connect to your mission the
sooner all aspects of your life will
fall into place
what is an unusual habit or an absurd
thing that you love in the old
television show candid camera reprise by
Ashton Kutcher Punk'd in more recent
times unsuspecting people were
videotaped coping in real-time with an
insane prearranged situation usually two
great ensuing hilarity I get endless
delight covertly ambushing unsuspecting
strangers with random acts of kindness
so for example after ordering my iced
latte I'll give a Starbucks barista a
$20 bill and tell him or her to cop the
person right after the person behind me
for whatever he or she wants and to give
that person that change as well
I don't do the person immediately behind
me who might suspect that I was the
mystery benefactor then I set my latte
from afar and watch the confusion give
way to smiles when the random
beneficiary realizes the unexpected
bounty sometimes the person leaves all
the changes a tip sometimes he or she
will pay it forward and gift
the next person behind a free coffee but
the beneficiary always leaves smiling
broadly and I know that I've unleashed a
positive ripple effect
in that person's community and to anyone
he or she encounters that day
I love spreading the magic hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them for book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number-one York Times
best seller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs com forward slash Tim I really
encourage you to take a look because you
will be impressed 99designs com forward
slash Tim 99designs has freelance
experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the Tao Seneca or you can
get concepts from multiple designers and
then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for
for design health resources etc
99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit
99designs comm forward slash tim and
click the link on the landing page you
can also find their samples of projects
from you guys
listeners who have used 9nn designs for
logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs comm forward
slash Tim
[Applause]
you